voici venu le temps des souliers dans la
cheminée et par la même occasion le
temps des panoplies mais que de
changements le receveur d'autobus et
l'agent de police n'ont plus leur succès
d'autrefois
avant-hier le mousquetaire nous y fait
hurler de joie
aujourd'hui tout juste si le cowboy
garde ses adeptes et le groupe public ne
va même plus aux petits radiologue qui
dévoilait à tous les futurs chirurgiens
ces joyeux secret l'uniforme du parfait
martien marque plutôt le goût des
garçons
et bien plus encore la panoplie du jeune
créateur retour à l'antique que
dira-t-on mais on demande l'avis des
familles
[Musique]